Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab, our topic today,
choice and human destinies. Yeah.
With the way we are is that the way we're
going to stay are very nicely put in
the last section we were talking about
baboons and their propensity to serious
change, which is a maybe or maybe
not. We don't really know. Yeah.
We'll known a thousand years.
Well let's switch our ape.
We'll go to Oregonians or just a rare
subset of human beings to set it up.
We were thinking a lot about um,
small groups on this show. You know,
cause that's what we are. We
are a small group primates.
That's the phrase that sometimes you use
to describe as humans and it's a phrase
that can carry some negative connotations.
As in we evolved in these small groups
that we are predisposed to be small
minded. No small is
not always a bad thing.
I'm gonna tell you a story now
that's a small group story. It's a,
just as a warning contains a moment
or two that's a tiny bit graphic,
but we hope you'll stick with it
because it's a really cool story.
Takes place in a small
town, like really small,
the kind of town where you can dial
the wrong number and still have a
conversation cause you know everybody.
So tell me where we are and,
and uh, downtown Silverton.
Essentially our downtown has not changed
since the late forties, early fifties.
Oh yes it has. But we'll get
to that. This is Stu Rasmussen.
He is our main character.
And a little while back stu gave
myself and producer Aaron Scott a tour,
the theater on the corner of the
old hardware store on this corner,
this tour of his favorite
place on earth. Silverton,
Oregon roots is about
40 miles from Portland.
It's about 40 years from
Portland actually, you know,
it's the town I grew up in and this is
my image for what I want silver to be.
You know,
I rode my bicycle down the street and
came to the hardware store to get going.
We're doing good. Vince,
is that happened to you?
A lot of people just honk and wave all
the time. Oh yeah. It's a small town.
Everybody knows, man,
if it were up to to this
town would never change.
It would stay frozen in that quaint Norman
Rockwell candy coated image from his
boyhood. The weird thing though is that
that image in his head would probably be
[inaudible] never have
included a guy like stu,
at least do as he is now and
if this is a show about change,
here is a story money pretty radical,
but it changed where you wouldn't
expect to find. Speaking of which,
can you describe where we are and what
we're looking at while we're standing in
front of the palace theater on the
corner of Oak and water street,
this is one of those gun with the wind
theaters with the big marquee and the
bulb lights and everything built in
1935 and then continuous operation ever
since steeples out some keys and opens
it up, but starting to get really cold.
He suggested that we do the interview
here in the towns only theater.
Even smells like a gilded age theater,
which at 1:00 PM still smelled like
popcorn from the previous night and was
filled with nothing but
200 empty red velvet seats.
Not what you expected in a small
town theater. Oh, this is beautiful.
Yeah. Okay. See you later. Okay,
thank you. You've left ourselves.
Sit right here. What do you think?
[inaudible] seats in the
house right in the middle.
Sit and pretend we're watching
the movie of your life
while there is a dull movement. Hardly.
So the movie of Stu begins in 1975 he's
27 and he's in a theater just like the
Seminole moment in my life was when
the rocky horror picture showcase
[inaudible]
stu is in the projectionist
booth cause that's his job.
He's changing the rails and at some
point during one of the musical members,
he glances at the screen and it was
like, oh, what was the, what was the,
Oh here was this movie with a
guy drag on screwed justice.
Triam is the best guy who is
the sweet trends fest. State
suction friends, sexual Transylvania.
Those are words that I've never heard.
Watch that again and again.
Fast forward 10 years. Do
you now owns the theater?
Just like his dad had beforehand.
He's an upstanding member of the town.
He's on the Silverton city
council. Then on the library board,
and then he starts to transform and
everyone will tell you it began with the
nails.
I think I probably started having my nails
done in 94 95 and it started out with
very masculine nails without Polish and
square ends and then slowly grew them
out. And then I went into what I
considered a masculine nail color of blue.
And then he says he gradually started to
paint them red and then he put acrylic
tips, which got longer and longer. This
was the first test. Did the community,
Hello Laurie? Who Do you
mean sir? How are you?
I could be at the theater taking tickets,
be dressed as usual and
his plaid shirt and jeans,
his hand would come out for their
tickets. And what is the healer?
Oh are those, you can't miss it. And you
know he had a long fingernail. Hello,
that's Dennis Bean.
Long Time Silver Tonia.
One time when I had to give him my
ticket and Megan to salvo, she's 17.
And he rips it and like his nails like
went down the palm of my hand and just
gave me the chills. Yeah.
For I think probably his nails were
the first thing most people notice.
Cal Palmer veterinarian and
city councilman born and
raised here and SilverTech
was their talk was oh, people
sitting, oh, definitely talk.
But it happens so gradually, which is
something you hear again and again.
It happened gradually, you know, first
it was the nails and, and then, uh,
at some point in time he changed the
focus of the movie theater and was really
making a game attempt to get new
releases and down in the theater.
And frequently, you know, when
there was a theme kind of movie,
he would get into costume.
My name is Ken Hector,
former mayor of short in Oregon.
And very often the costume
would be female attire.
This is step two of Steve's very careful
transition according to everyone we
spoke with for years after
the nails. He would quote,
promote that week's movie by dressing up
or one of the new star wars movies was
out and it a coincidence he
was dressed as queen on
the dollar. I love you.
Whatever name is from the movie.
Years ago you remember, uh,
some years ago there was a movie
called my big Fat Greek wedding.
That's John Bach, also
a lifelong silver Tony.
And that whole day he wandered
around town in a wedding dress.
The complete with the veil. That of
course got everybody talking. You know,
a lot of people laughed about it. I don't
think people put it together with um,
this is the, the web.
She's a registered nurse, sexuality,
transgender or any of those things.
I think we thought he was just dressing
up to go along with this. Uh, yeah,
with his movies. There was clearly a,
let's go by the movie theater tonight
cause we've got to know what Stew's
wearing for stu. This was just the
beginning of something. He was,
he wasn't just clowning around. When
did your gender complexities begin?
In probably 14 or 15.
I think I was a shy young man
and interfacing with girls.
My mother was a bit strange on on that
in the girls who are evil and they would,
no girl was good enough for her
son and Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah Dah.
So did you date at all? Not
until I was out of high school.
So girls were kind of scary. It
sounds like girls were scary. Yeah,
well everybody else went on dates.
He says he would build computers from
scratch and even today in his basement
you'll find an entire electrical
shop like God, fun stuff,
RF generators, spectrum analyzer, logic
analyzer or the logic, analyze it.
In any case do says the best that
he can explain himself gender wise.
It's just to say that when
he looks in the mirror,
he likes himself better when
he's dressed as a woman.
I don't know how to describe it.
It's just, um, I can't understand it.
I mean, some people like to dress up
and look like a cowboy or a lumberjack,
whatever, you know,
it's your mental image of yourself that
you look in the mirror and you like.
So after the nails,
after dozens of episodes of
socially acceptable cross-dressing,
Stu took the next step. He began
to perform some experiments,
like he would go to the lumber
yard just to get some stuff,
a couple of pounds in nails or something.
All the while he would
be wearing a padded bra.
There is flannel shirt just to see
what would happen. So this for you,
it was like a test. It was like a
calculated test to absolutely age.
If it was possible, if I could
survive with breasts. Okay.
So when he was 52 he drove into
Portland, visited a doctor,
put him to sleep and the doctors
made two small incisions,
one under each breast, about an
inch and a half or two inches long.
And they pulled back
the skin on each side,
slid in an uninflated balloon and then
pumped it up with water until the skin
was stretched to the point that
it was almost transparent. Hmm.
That sounds very painful. Was it?
Well, I was asleep at the time,
but when he woke up he was a different
man because he now had several pounds of
new stuff hanging off his chest. What
were you thinking at that moment?
I was thinking what I done, it was like,
there's no going back.
I can remember being in a Max
place downtown at a table and uh,
he was coming across the street with
his breasts prominently showing,
and it was the first time any of us
realized that he had actually had surgery
and one lady was going, Oh look, look.
And the other lady was going to look
across the street and Oh my God, look,
it's too, my God, what is he doing?
It just sort of shocking.
There was a buzz around town.
This is a situation where he'd
walked by and then heads would turn,
hushed voices would ensue. Yes. Basically,
this is Victoria sage
Stew's longtime girlfriend.
They've been together for 36 years.
So we would be walking in our local
goodwill and we'd be a few miles away from
each other. And I would hear that
used to be [inaudible] Rasmussen,
like he had changed somehow [inaudible]
trying to fulfill that body image.
He's gotten his head but he's also going
to in way asked you to adjust to your
body image of your mate. Has
that been difficult? Hmm.
No. Okay. No, I'm sorry.
If you, if want to get kinky about
it, a man would is kind of cool,
Huh?
Okay. Did, uh,
was there ever any concern there
was for me? Um, not so much for Stu.
I think partly because he didn't hear
as many whispers as I felt I did,
but I was concerned for the theater
business. Not without reason.
A lot of kids in the town stop coming
to the theater cause their parents
wouldn't let them.
Ticket sales took a hit and it wasn't
long before pickup trucks full of teenage
boys would drive by the
theater yelling slurs.
Oh I don't know that I go so far
as well. Yeah, I guess I guess
[inaudible]
in fact it is a slur I guess.
And so you get to this point in
the sped up movie narrative of Stu.
This point right here where even though
he took it so slowly and was so careful,
it's still easy to imagine things
turning ugly. I don't know.
What was that movie about?
The boy that was a, you know,
drug and beat to death because he was
gay in a small town in the Midwest.
You know what a waste of your shepard.
Yeah. Might be a little extreme.
But according to Linda Web Silverton's
not so different from Laramie, Wyoming.
We are Matthew Shepard lift. It's
a small town, very traditional,
very conservative. You know,
you got a lot of rednecks in silver and
so Dennis beam puts it so it's not crazy
to expect the worst.
But here's the surprise.
[inaudible] call. Right. And the whole
reason we came here to Silverado my page,
January 5th, 2009 the
worst did not happen.
[inaudible] there was no
redneck rebellion. In fact,
the opposite happened right the right
hand. Something historic it after me. Hi.
Hi. On January 5th
thousand and nine the town
of Silverton elected stu mayor.
How did the city of Silverton
Marion County for congratulate
has elected the nation's first openly
transgender mayor nation's first openly
transgender mayor. This is a real
turn off here. This election take,
do revenues slide as openly transgendered
as he runs his hometown in heels.
Speaking of heels, this is
in fact the sound of stews.
Four inch heels pounding on linoleum
as he goes to a city council meeting.
Hello Harold. Couldn't be better.
How are you? Good. Yeah, no.
Call Us, you know, city
elitist or whatever.
But a mayor in a plunging v-neck
sweater and a black miniskirt.
Not what you would expect. Any
tiny conservative Republican town.
So we wanted to know, you know,
why did this happen here? Wow.
So producer Aaron Scott and I walked
around town for a couple of days and we
interviewed dozens of people, including
gentleman, guy named Ken Hector,
who stu beat out for mayor.
He's a conservative Republican.
Definitely not one of Steve's big fans.
It was just a difference in philosophy
about, I don't want to sound pretentious,
but you know, as a mayor,
I think there's certain expectations
about professionalism that you should
exhibit.
He would come in with a tight clinging
top with cleavage down to here that
you're almost pointing at your belly
button there a little bit higher. Come on.
You know when you're
at the council meeting,
show some dignity here and just dress
in the appropriate attire for the
occasion. Can't even try to get the city
council to impose a dress code on Stu.
But when we asked them, you know,
are you surprised that the town has
embraced stu and even gone so far as to
elect a mayor? He said, uh,
no, not in this case. You know,
is a rarity in that. You know,
there's a lot of people in this
town who are extremely religious,
very conservative people were at a
stranger who came into town suddenly,
I'm sure that the support and
perception might've been different.
But you're talking about a
native son who grew up here
and he said, still runs
the only theater in town.
So he's out there every weekend standing
out in front of the palace or taking
tickets. Everybody knows
him. Not only that anymore,
back in the day he used
to be the cable guys.
So he's literally been
in everybody's homes.
He's still the guy you call if you
have trouble with your computer.
So it might sound strange
to you, but it's really not.
And that is when it hit me actually
under the right circumstances.
A small town can be like the
most progressive place on earth.
Oh. [inaudible]
and it's exactly because
everyone's all up in your grill.
You were forced to know people. Like for
instance, how long have you known sue?
Oh my goodness. I grew up with
Stu. I mean we, um, I read,
everyone's do is like an alter boy.
The church is my brother. This is Suzy.
Seamless retired t-shirts. Yeah, his
parents and my parents were friends.
Like a lot of folks in Silverton,
she has known stu for so long and,
and in so many different contexts that
you can't do that New York thing with
him. Where are you?
Like you see someone on the sidewalk
and you size them up instantly and think
freak no to her. He's way too
complicated for that, you know,
to her he's do the alter boys
do the computer games? Yeah,
I probably would call McGee to do the
city council man is do the mayor or he's
just do just do, just, just do whatever.
That's him. You know, go on about
your business. You have to be clear.
A lot of the people we
talk to these facts,
some of the same folks
who said yes dues just to,
are still not happy about
the situation. No. I mean,
I don't think that's across dresser.
They either felt it was morally wrong.
As in the case of this minister
Tom Smith and Genesis one 27 says,
so God created man in his
own image. In the more,
some folks like Linda Webb's husband
John just felt like he takes it way too
far. It's right there. It's in your face.
He dresses Kinda like a streetwalker.
You feel that that's
confrontational? I do,
but most of the people who had objections,
it was a little more nuanced and
it went something like [inaudible].
Yes. Well, I,
my personally did not vote for him for
mayor because I didn't feel it was a good
idea to have someone that looked
like that representing us.
But on the other hand, he is a good
man and he's got this town at heart.
In other words, according to John Bach,
the problem really isn't stu or the
town or the way he gets the outside.
All those people out there who
are going to hear about stu
and then judge them,
which is what makes November 25th,
2008 such an interesting day.
Steve had just been elected mayor,
he'd squeaked it out by about 400 votes
but he hadn't yet been sworn in when a
group of Christian extremists from Kansas
showed up in town and started marching
up and down main street yelling at people
and at one point they even unfurled
and American flag put it on the ground
and stepped on it just to show how
offensive
they found students. It's our duty
to not here and preach to everyone.
Man is disgusting.
These folks hate stu cause they will
not by any means warn him about to send
this, taking him to hell
closet and then bringing up signs and
key things like a god hates overtake.
God hates your mayor. God
hates fags. Your pastor,
it's an abomination for a man put on a
woman's clothes and to be the opposite
sex. If he folks from the town decided
it's to start a counter protest,
we stood across the street from these
people by and large, just a few guys.
At first, no earlier,
someone had suggest all the guys ought
to dress up as girls and all the girls.
I did dress up these guys. Jase Davidson
said, isn't this a reaction? Was here,
right there? He was in a dress
every time. You Bet. Impressed.
[inaudible] but that really actually
was the first time he says it. At first,
he and the two or three other
guys who had on women's clothing,
it felt a little weird, but then
people just started coming.
It was just amazing.
Of a couple of hundred people.
I mean men dressed like women,
women dressed like men.
Some of the people that I sat down there
were surprising because I had labeled
them in my head as conservative and
people drive by people signs God loves.
So to God's love, Stu costumes,
the town was really alive when the crowd
just kept getting bigger and bigger.
Who were you? What were you thinking
at that moment? From what I understand,
you were standing off to the side just
watching what was going through your
mind. Yeah,
well honestly I tried to discourage people
from even giving them the time of day
saying, don't give them any attention.
I couldn't get that to happen.
They were so angry and
they came out 200 people, men in dresses,
grandmothers, babies. That's,
it's just amazing that that
was the town. That wasn't me.
Sorry, I get a little emotional.
That must've been a turning point for you.
The biggest one? Yeah.
[inaudible]
perhaps to Aaron Scott who did a huge
chunk of the reporting for that piece in
co-produced it with me.
We'll be right back.
Okay. So that story with,
we did that about six,
maybe seven years ago and it just
feels like the world is different now.
Like with regards to transgender
issues, even the language we use,
I mean has changed it.
Back then we said transgendered and
now we would just say transgender,
but with Caitlyn Jenner in
the news and all this stuff,
we just thought wondered like how things
changed for stew in these last six,
seven years.
So
hello all the time on time
we decided to send producer, reporter
Aaron Scott back to Silverton,
sit down with stu and with
students, partner Victoria,
the headset just to catch up.
I mean it's been seven years since
our, we'll be going on seven years,
six years since we ran
the story the first time.
What has been going on in your world?
Well, since the election
that's been about it. So
the first thing you told me was that he
got reelected after two years and then
he was reelected again. And
then after years is mayor, he's,
he's no out of the game.
Hallelujah. I am truly
enjoying my vacation.
And he did tell me that back
when the story first aired,
things did get kind of nutty.
Well, you know, it's probably the most
unusual phone call we've ever received.
Worst Victoria and I were sitting at home,
the phone rang and it was as a
fellow from New York City who said,
I was bicycling on Manhattan listening
to the original radio lab piece,
and you thought it would be really
fun to do my life story as a musical.
I don't know what I feel, but I know
it's a big deal. Then they reveal
and he did. That fellow is Andrew Russell.
He put on a big production up in
Seattle. It got standing ovation.
It's the most surreal and
bizarre experience in my life.
Sitting in an auditorium with 400
strangers watching as in song and dance.
My life goes by.
He can call me, she and she can
call me. He and he can call me.
She and she can call me.
He and he can call me.
He and she can call me. She when you
refer to me by Jan.
So there was this musical
which seemed to do pretty well.
And then a movie producer
called him up and said that he,
he wanted to option Stew's life for a
movie and now Victoria says those whispers
that they used to get those have turned
into people wanting autographs or
stopping them in the shoe store
and saying, aren't you stew?
Aren't you that bear? Can I get a
picture with you? Sure, there's Israeli,
no, what's the big deal? God Woo.
But one of the most interesting things
for me was that a lot of that attention
was at the beginning these
days to says that, you know,
his transgender issues have grown in,
in the national news and on TV shows.
Stu says that back in Silverton,
the fact that he's transgender,
it's become pretty much passe.
So here we are,
Woo.
He says it's just kind of routine
now for him and everyone else,
except he did say there's this one
thing every time the story airs or re,
which it does from time to time
when it, when it goes, the phone starts
ringing and we can tell where it's from.
He says he gets these calls from people
who are struggling with their own gender
issues or trying to figure out how to
come out to their families and people
actually call your home phone.
Yeah. Usually anonymously.
They won't identify themselves necessarily
because they're still either closeted
or not really ready to come
out, but they're saying,
thank you so much for being yourself
and for telling your story to others so
that I can, you know, I can validate
my life from that. Thank you.
Does that ever get old? Hm. No. Um,
for somebody who was in
the position that I was in,
made the change and then to have other
people either following along or,
you know, emulating it
in one way or another,
it's very gratifying because it validates
life and it says why you weren't a
complete waste of time. A lot more
than a lot of people get. Yeah.
[inaudible]
special thanks to producer Annie Mcewen
for helping us on all the tough day
parts of this year.